I smell this Oh bear oh my goodness very
strong Wow
hi I'm Mike oh and I am Japanese hi I'm
you Tony I'm Japanese
hi I'm Chloe and I am British and we are
swapping snacks today yeah I don't know
anything about Japanese snacks honestly
like I've probably seen some around here
and there but nothing that I can think
of in particular so yes are you good
with spicy stuff or I can do spice like
flavor this is a might what it's a puff
it's like Cheetos but it's really good
the flavor I don't want to tell you what
it is because I don't want you to know
before you eat it
so these are three types and they are
around crease then they're kind of hot
all the kids put them on me into their
fingers and they eat them off their
fingers it's just a more fun way of
eating snacks oh oh look if you're like
wondering every single thing good yeah
it's gonna say it's like bugles right
where you to put it on your finger you
sing with that one oh it's a ring policy
so this place is BBQ beef I don't think
I've even had this way but unless I
change the name because it used to be
they do kind of taste like ramen noodle
ooh like just the heart like without
cooking yeah it's hard it's not a
photography
um more like a cracker but good it
smells like shrimp actually it smells
like fish which is not vasilieva like
smell wise I'm sure it will taste good
though from the picture can you tell I
can know it kind of good
they're like salty and sweet and I don't
know what else this is a really hard
favour to like pinpoint it always looks
like a pepper I don't think it's a place
to get that fat I don't know this is
really weird I cannot tell oh it's a
spicy fish egg so yeah
that's what these are like fish okay
that makes sense yeah I really don't
like this one of them but I really like
the taste but we're always like oh no
and then they don't like it but I didn't
get that either I was kinda like is it a
sausage I would go for that one IG would
go sir that's not yeah I actually like
these better than the Hoonah news which
is blasphemous Wow pasty Oh there's
something very delicious about pests you
like the word pests we couldn't pass
tools passed away less cool so these
around trees fruit pastilles they're a
sweet that's like kind of there's like a
sugar crust on the outside and then it's
like a gummy on the inside I have never
heard of a crispy gummy I mean bad way
of bringing it it's like it's crunchy
and then it's soft on the inside because
of the like caramelized sugar on the top
mine is called beste Chaney gummies oh I
like how it says the flavor is Italian
grape I didn't like American grape
flavor so I'm hoping I'll like
if they're not exactly the same well you
think they are they're not the same I
think it's a little stronger than
America no I mean I know I'm wondering
maybe you won't like no I like yeah
growing up I never really had great fun
even stuff but that's one of the slaves
who didn't really have and this is like
real grape juice like real grapes no
artificial this is like pureed grapes in
a bowl and it's delicious yeah I mean
I've tried that brand stuff before they
are very powerful smelling yeah
Japanese artificial treatment what's the
best color to have the red one oh yeah
mmm I think this is strawberry flavor
but it tastes actually like strawberries
are already yeah yeah all right I see I
smell this oh oh my goodness very strong
wow this tastes like I just ate like
great powder but it's like a really good
consistent thing like I like you chew on
it tastes like crazy grape flavor yeah
it's a different I like it I know
actually is like artificial tasting in
terms of like they take the purple one
of this one and then the purple one of
that one I feel like yeah yours is a
little bit more red mine's like darker
but yeah oh they don't smell like
anything really
when bias untreated there Roundy's with
decimals as as much as I like artificial
or not artificial like the grape flavor
of this gummy I think I prefer this one
know what the consistency of these
brought up I like the flavor of them
what do you say
Borbon Borbon okay I don't think we do
so these are open I believe but they're
chocolate favourite biscuits they're
like crispy like - like cracking
biscuits would like chocolate like
spread in the middle basically this is
pretty much the Japanese version of this
cookie because I see the word bourbon on
the cookie I think I'm gonna like it was
more because you have your actual
chocolate on it I love chocolate
whereas these are just chocolate flavor
I don't like things that come in like a
sandwich though milk chocolate and
digestive biscuits
[Music]
alright I've ever waste of plastic rest
be honest those are smaller than
advertised
neither ate like actual size or
something on that oh this is like a
little cookie sandwich it doesn't look
like there's that much cream it's very
light on the chocolate you would think
it would be chocolatier like a chocolate
aftertaste as a person
yeah like this one yeah kind of don't
taste great
well this is immediately cool because of
the ship obviously I already messed it
up with my fingers but it looks so cool
if I like the real chocolate on this
like the chocolate took tracker or
biscuit ratio
oh yeah it's like halfway towards being
a small because it's like the biskits
with their how I see it I've noticed
though like when I do go get cookies
from Japanese stores that a lot of them
are individually packaged it tastes good
I guess they should be more
environmentally conscious yes Thank You
Jordan warm Wow
I really love the Japanese sexo example
I was really impressed with all the
Japanese snacks it's really they were
really really good it's great getting to
try stuff that like another cultures
grown up with cuz it's more similar than
you think
I think overall the Japanese snacks like
she had a lot more flavor - that's not
British snack yeah and I really think
I'd like that great flavor but because
it wasn't too strong that's why that's
why I liked it smells good
Wow everything you kind of smelled on
the Japanese so it would have like a
very strong smell but then the taste
with a little bit that's so true yeah
that's a good point
everything okay filling the packets
you're like what am I gonna put in my
mouth and then it's like fine some
aren't it's more like aftertaste kinda
thing but the fruit pastels surprised me
a lot I think the only one that like I
preferred was the fruit pastilles which
just like this is just a jars classic
but every other one I think I preferred
the Japanese actually I do like my
Japanese snacks but I feel like there's
a lot more to try as well
[Music]
you